and you can see it's like this log base
B of X equals n now the one thing you
want to understand when you're working
with logarithms is that exponential
functions and logarithmic functions
they're inverses of each other so
basically what it is it's like squaring
and square rooting multiplying dividing
adding and subtracting they undo one
another so what you can do when you're
given something in this form like this
is instead of taking the log base B of X
you can exponentiate both sides using
the same base here so this is raising it
to this power and what happens is these
are inverses they undo one another and
now you have it in exponential form now
if you have something in exponential
form like this we can do the inverse and
say I'm gonna take the log okay base B
of the right side and you want to do the
same thing take the log base B of the
left side to keep the equation balanced
but you can see these are inverses of
one another so they cancel one another
out and you can see now we're back to
the original equation that we started
with so basically knowing how to switch
back and forth is a really important
skill when you're working with
logarithms and exponential functions so
let's go through a few examples this
first one 3 to the x equals 10 we want
to solve for our variable X right so
instead of exponentiating what we're
gonna do is we're going to take the log
base 3 of both sides of this equation so
what I did as you can see I just brought
this 3 to the X down and the 10 down
what I did is I took the log base 3 of
both sides because log base 3 and
exponential base 3 those are inverses
they undo one another
and now you've got your variable X by
itself okay starting with me so far the
second example we're starting off of the
log we're trying to solve for a variable
X we want to get rid of this log so
we're gonna do the inverse of taking the
logarithm which is to exponentiate okay
raise both sides using base five the key
is you want to make sure that these
bases are the same so exponential
functions and logarithmic functions
they're inverses they undo one another
and so we just get x equals five to the
fourth power which we know is 625 okay
two more examples now this one here
we've got two to the X minus 5 power
equals 50 we want to get that variable
by itself so we say you want
exponentiating let's just take the log
base two of both sides let me squeeze
that in there and you can see those on
do you want to know that they cancel
each other out and so we're left with X
minus five equals log base two of 50 all
we have to do is add five to both sides
and you can see we've got X by itself
now before I do this last example I just
want to mention that if you're preparing
for the AC T or the SAT and you want
some additional help with the math
section check out my huge AC T math
review video course and a huge SAT math
review video course they're available on
my website they're also available
through the links on my YouTube about
page and I'll have a link here as well
but let's go through this last example
we want to get X by itself we can see
that this is a log base three we want to
get rid of that log base three by doing
the inverse of the opposite right so
we're going to exponentiate both sides
using the same base those cancel one
another out and now you can see we have
X minus two equals three to the fourth
add two to both sides and you can see
you have x equals 3 to the fourth plus 2
3 to the fourth is 81 so really just
looking at 81 plus 2 which is 83 and you
got it so I hope this helps you to
understand how to work with switching
forms between the Log form and the
exponential form
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon